[Music]
today's episode is brought data from
t-mobile
we're live sometimes you forget hey guys
we're here to talk about our honest
trailer with four skunk on Skull Island
we had a surprise this morning we don't
want to tell anybody we had a couple
hours but we had the director himself
Jordan vogt-roberts appeared in this
trailer to write his own on his trailer
we're gonna talk all about how that went
down what that was like sure you said
we'll watch the trailer with you again
as well sheriff you might a little out
of takes that we didn't make the final
cut Andy's sitting here next to Joe
starry Joe hello how was your Labor Day
weekend it was very nice I watched a
samurai cop you guys ever watched that
uh yeah that's the red line is wonderful
guy he shows up with them a lot Oh does
he
yeah it's it's a fun movie okay really
really really terribly fun movie Jeana
Gilbert what you do I went to Disneyland
got a massage part of a club what's it
called club 33 movie theme
exactly dan tomorrow yeah it's chilled
out yeah a great long weekend caught up
on a few bad movies that I hadn't seen
from earlier this year and they were bad
boys yeah
oh man we shopped around for my wife's
Emmy stuff and we randomly ran into Dan
girlfriend for safe to say video starts
now so let's be honest this is why I
think we all sort of said it this was
not a movie we probably would have
jumped at had we not had the opportunity
to work with Jordan it's been a fantasy
of yours from the get goes like I want a
filmmaker to work on their own on his
trailer and dreams finally have we had a
couple of chimed in off the record they
did want to be named yeah but this was
the first official like let's do and I'm
him here give me a cut why are we doing
and he wrote out did he look he even
said some stuff he's like I don't thing
I can say that some things too much
because he wants to bill I think he I
think he found a perfect way to sort of
really honestly criticize it without
getting too much into yeah you make a
movie a lot of weird stuff happens yeah
so I was I was I applauded his honesty
and and just wherewithal of knowing how
to do this the right way without you
know I don't know pissing Studios off
whatever I thought you did a really nice
job about it it was this stuff that he
knew he did wrong yeah stuff that he
felt like he still was trying to fix
they never got to fix stuff like that
but this was a movie though itself we
criticized it together dan did yeah and
I went back and forth on this I was in
favor of it you were against it I think
we both agree I mean it's a fun monster
movie I think it's where we both met it
out but it had too many characters and a
lot of things that he did sort of focus
but this is goes right down the alley of
a movie that if we hadn't had a chance
to work with Jordan on it I don't know
if we would have done it because it's
very difficult to do an honest trailer
of a movie that's fine we all thought it
was really good not some issues at the
end points they're not terrible
tightrope that movies like this walk
where it's like this is a fun and now
I'm moving on with my life movie and I
like on this side Kong Skull Island
Falls and then if you fall to the left
your Jurassic world like it's a weird
right now in the middle it's a tough act
to yeah the movies right down the middle
are always the toughest to make honest
trailers for just because there's
they're fine they're not the best movies
we've ever seen but they're not the
worst movies ever seen there'd
entertaining they go there and so I
think we would have probably avoided
this movie and we probably would have
done it I think is that one plan why
don't you do it
we were Dan to have to watch it I think
you did you tonight I was like you know
what I'm always behind watches tougher
honest trailers you're doing it I'm
gonna clear off the night three Sun
three hours of it and then the next
morning or the day or it's like oh yeah
Jordans in so I don't think I'm gonna do
it and like Dan was visibly upset that
was one of those that was a genuine like
well no he was like why couldn't you
tell me this trailer vault is growing of
actually start beyond not beyond Star
Trek yeah so how we got Jordan let's go
there I guess right to that point he had
done a video for us on a comic-con where
he was there and showed up for an
interview and how much I was house art
schedule people are coming at the same
time you only have five minutes it's the
talent you got to fit them in your
studio get them in and out he showed up
but graciously was there to talk about
Kong coming on blu-ray etc and then max
landis was in the wings waiting to do
his portion for Dirk Gently season 2 and
if you didn't know max and max2 the sole
whole tirade about the luteum
whose nihilism nihilism of Kong and this
whole long thing the nihilism yes
everything nothing matters it's like no
one has a point
it's all just sort of to prove that it's
all for nothing and it's like but anyway
so it was unclear how if max actually
liked the movie or not it was even in
the his critique of it like couldn't
rotella was he's throwing Shane or was
he just saying what it was
so in Jordan saw-max there and there was
a little bit of like Oh max landis he
called max out live on the air and we
had this little pulled max in and they
had a nice little conversation and they
had a nice fair respectful conversation
max did like the movie and was just
remarking I was something he hadn't seen
before this this idea of nihilism and
Jordan was like yeah there's a little
bit of that but they had their sort of
test the thing and then Jordan ended the
interview by saying look I love
criticism but when I'm not looking
forward to as his honest trailer guys
ripping apart the movie and that's when
I sort of had to jump in and was like
hey man I think he was also mistaking us
for cinemasins at the time even then
that's all the thing that you know yeah
this is before his way way before his
rant yeah he had been calling out
cinemasins it doesn't like I'm not here
to cause cinemasins that's not worth
doing here but he was calling out
Simmons and I was like look man that's
fine but that's not we don't do those we
do this I think there's a common
misconception I'm sure they have the
same problem of people think we're the
same reasons and us are the same things
we are not we'd our own people we do our
own things and he's my caimans like
that's not we don't do those we do on
his trailers and we'd love if you wanted
to do it come come write it and we'd
love for you to be honest until then he
said yes and so I didn't think he'd
actually follow up on it weeks we did
and then then then came the drama yeah
which was Jordan called out cinemasins
is everything wrong with Kong Skyland on
YouTube and it became a whole big thing
quite a while for quite a while
we had already booked him to do this for
September to have him do it and so the
timing was not to jump into that flave
flames fan whatever could he call that
blame fire flame wars yeah it was the
Vietnam of so great stretched on and
kept going yeah he really he really kept
going
calming the planet boundaries so we
could not address that and the cost of
cooking knowledge well this is probably
even better for us that we are gonna do
it so that's how it all came down and so
then when that came down it was like it
wasn't about us trying to fan those
flames like I don't want to get we are
not here to knock on cinemasins or do
any of that stuff he seems to want to
but that's on him
but when we do this it was like look as
long as we can make fun of you make fun
of us and make fun of the drama we're in
let's do this and that's what it became
a guy I don't I was like I do not want
this to be like this is why soon as soon
sucks cuz if you feel that way that's
your own thing but that's not what we're
here to do this is just let's talk about
the movie you make fun of us make fun of
you make of the whole thing and he was
down so I think that was where it
finally net it out and that's when we
got to do the trailer thought something
yeah I think the context that everyone's
gonna tell everyone to skip over yeah
yeah we all have some point in US
citizens Jordan all of some red letter
media now should've ended there's so
many employment and we also do nothing
to that has no impact on anyone no
purpose to serve so like you can take it
seriously and think that all three sides
have their sides or realize that like
we're all picking apart and talking
about a monkey movie
nothing is more effective than criticism
of a movie four months after criticism
yeah I know I'm a father son flick bit
but I see all sides always there there
are always two sides to every story yeah
but it was strange that this all
coalesced like during this is like you
know we knew this was in the cards and
then two weeks ago we're like oh [ __ ]
this is gonna be more Jordan is a genius
and new how do I get attention for this
blu-ray to get me to do more
we advertising it did get attention for
the movie I look at got attention to
cinemasins like I'm sure they saw nice
little bump and enjoyed it people were
watching it all presses all all press is
good press so what they saying yeah we
would have felt cheap if we didn't if
that had happened and we were just like
let's just ignore it like yeah that
would have felt dumb and as I'm sure
we'll both be happy about
due to this I'm surely now people will
continually persist in linking us
together yes forever as one entity cuz
even Jordan you want to know anything
wrong with Kong skyline I'll tell you
think work on Shana Simpsons we were not
not doing that we were like if Jordan
calls shade that's on we're just
providing the platform for him but I do
think we made a point and I did not want
it to be that issue and I think Jordan
probably would have gone further there I
just didn't wanted I was like no that's
not what we're that's we don't agree
with that we're not there for that so I
think it was all in good fun and I'm
glad that he was mailed but in front of
us we were able make fun of him and we
were able to make fun of the drama in
itself to me that was the saving grace
for at all yep final thoughts before we
watch it about the process are let's do
it
video starts now video starts now
you guys forgot your capes remember the
thing we were talking about two minutes
ago
oh he's gift that he gonna be so sorry
it's really good concepts at the King
Kong movies a new film will take the
giant a bear with me what if there was a
King Kong movie but it was also the 70s
for take the original King Kong movie
was in the censors it was made and set
in the seventies okay because I've never
seen it because everyone has always said
it's dog [ __ ] the city jessica leigh
bridges of King I've always been told
it's awful so I've just never seen it
it's a slow look it's in the 70s so he
has time to grow big enough to fight
Godzilla ants in the seventies cuz like
what else can you do with a King Kong
movie make it a period piece oh and also
because he went on a rant about this cuz
other this makes sense for why the
satellite technology could reveal the
island that had previously never been
found
yeah people were thinking about it I
think he just was encouraging yeah yeah
I appreciate that he talked about he
wanted to bring a new tape to the movie
and like how the idea of doing like a
Apocalypse Now King Kong movie appealed
him so here we are in the 70s I like
that I'd that didn't that was not what I
did I will say I very meekly flagged
that there was a 70 set King Kong movie
before and I should have a ding on us I
guess I strap in for a period piece more
retro than a Vietnam vet lasting quite a
Sabbath on a real real tape player
in a monster flick that for once
delivers on the giant monster battles
but also tries to be an extended
metaphor for the Vietnam War where Skull
Island is Nam
Sam Jackson is the US Hong Kong is the
Vietcong the giant lizards are Vietcong
in the South Vietnamese and Tom
Hiddleston cantata fighting Dino bird
it's an allegory you know what I'm
totally lost
let's just watch the ape hit the dragon
with a bow propeller suit up with
monarch a company devoted to launching
the giant monster movie franchise we
specialize on the hunt for massive
organisms they'll travel to an island
that's been isolated since your defines
a Jurassic world if you will - all the
cheapest dogs you have a place where
everything that can go call will go call
up a mad dash to turn this monster into
a sympathetic character before he bites
Godzilla in the sequel quite works like
Godzilla - socks off into the ocean
after what you didn't see was them all
immediately drowning from the tsunami he
caused by now but doesn't quite work out
he's huge exactly his place we would
make all that water competitive at all
just but you need to end with like oh
they're the hero now I guess because
they want to make them fight so you got
it but who's the but but now they're
both the hero right so well I'm sure
they're saying Kahn's mom's name and
then
yeah because then in the third act
Mothra shows up with those little tiny
ladies that win this weigh-in the
clamshell yeah I hope so
oh god that beam and then I planted
people I triggered with that bat maybe
that dragons or whatever that's called
whatever they were in Kong's go Island
they come out of vents in the ground yes
Pacific Rim the kaijus come out of vents
in the ground is this setting up an
eventual the Hollow Earth see I mean
that how do we gonna stop the code which
was the bad ones to code you yeah let's
get condo just come take them out
together yeah Sam robot sir on Godzilla
and King Kong what if what if Jax teller
from Sunday
legendary call us we think Yuma crafted
King Kong Godzilla chief compatible
confirm yeah certainly please make that
go to shop yes but what does it look
like the thing that they're piloting
planet yeah like that right okay mom I
see the comet surface and Mothra why did
you say that
kudos job who was that that deserves a
call again its Tara Steiner she may not
have been the first but she's the one
that I saw yeah a mad dash to turn this
monster into a sympathetic character
before he bites Godzilla in the sequel
oh he's not so bad
I mean his parents are dead so he's
basically a real a bad man right I'm
like 25 get ready for a brand new
version of pop culture's best non Donkey
Kong complete with WWE wrestling moves
jungle parkour skills and the
inexplicable ability to sneak up on you
like a ninja
he's a 100 foot tall eight why does no
one see or hear him coming and shouldn't
have the island be wrecked from Kong
just walking around really guys this is
the best you've got huh
who's that oh no its Skull Island
director Jordan oh those cons tough all
over
that is his pool house this was a fake
office that we made on Stefan he brought
some concept for us and we can add some
here I used all the toner yes this is to
break the fourth wall that was a office
upstairs doesn't really have photos of
himself Joe cannot have him do this pose
with the picture of him it's worth
noting that we had originally scripted
him interrupting audio-wise
right earlier and what trailer and I
think mutually we decided that it was a
little confusing so you're like let's
save the reveal till right before cuz
there's like job and say something's
like wrong who is that yeah yeah it's
didn't like audio mixing I didn't work
microphones yeah it didn't quite work so
all right let's see Jordan yep I should
have known if we criticized your movie
long enough you'd appear look you guys
can criticize my movie all you want all
I ask is if you do it have some in merit
you didn't let me finish though I had a
whole section ready on King Kong's
missing ding-dong it was gold it really
the where's the dick joke again as if
you didn't already do that in the honest
trailer for Zootopia Donna funny names
are no it's not that tyre is not
bankruptcy you cannot cause he did a
good section on like what do you I guess
it did make it in about like what do you
expect me to put a giant Watchmen well
yeah we tried to fit them and it didn't
work but yeah that was a funny line
music he just I'd loved that like the
dick joke and now it's been we've now
been called off I called along Scala
director Jordan Ford Robert writers
you're free to put no dick continue back
to boobs guys back to dude it's just a
joke I love film criticism it's an
important part of this art form but you
want to know my biggest critic is me you
want to know everything been wrong with
Kong Skull Island I will tell you that's
true he's really hard on Jordan
vogt-roberts
okay here we go try to enjoy a movie
with major structural problems that
spends the whole first act bringing the
cast together only to split everyone
apart
ten minutes later yeah that was going
for the emotional simplicity ladies but
ended up with the complexity of alien
versus Predator
harsh meat great human characters like
Johnson's we should point out in case
people are think that he's just lent his
name like we have him say like he let's
clarify we wrote a draft yeah let's
bully tell you we defend her and Joan
every guys wrote a draft and then we
with notes from all the sweets was sat
there and then we sort of sent to him
knowing he wanted to do a section of his
own or you're gonna get unum are sure
but we sort of put together our thoughts
and then the ones he was connecting to
and agreed to we then sort of rejiggered
to the tower format to make it trailer
II because I remember that line he wrote
that line but he said of was it was a
valine covenant covenant yeah then he
took made it even worse he gave us stuff
that we didn't even think of or walk of
like oh yeah the structure really
doesn't work and oh we had stuff about
the characters but we didn't put it in
the same terms of like no one has an ark
the dock he sent us of like things wrong
with my movie is like Jesus trailer he
came in like that
these are his thoughts the only thing we
did was massage a little bit to our
format a little yeah yeah this was all
him me great human characters like john
c reilly everybody keep your wig then
before human characters and more and
more and more and more because most
contemporary blockbusters have too many
characters and most of them should have
been cut or consolidated but hey I'm the
director that's on me like the living
legend John Goodman the guy you enter
the movie with then drops out cuz he has
nothing to do but spout exposition
whose greatest call but as human
character isn't a complete else
sometimes let you punch line about how
specific the typecasting has gotten for
Toby Kebbell and Andy Serkis
yeah it's like all right I can appear as
myself and be decent but more often I'm
known for specifically performance
capturing giant Apes you're talking it's
because that circus was King Kong too
right yeah circus also come on cope and
then if he Kobe was Toby was Toby was
Koba circus was Kong yeah Cesar very
convincing giant ape monster not quite
as convincing as a southerner movie like
he I remember watching the movie like
and I didn't know that he played Kong so
when I saw that he played songs like
that makes so much sense yeah they just
didn't have anything to do with them but
they felt bad cuz they wanted like you
know like they used to put Robert
Englund a nightmare no Street movies
they just want the poor guy to step out
from behind the mask and yeah be in the
movie but he's like on his own and then
just is gone I mean I guess you could
say he's there to provide motivation
which is fine but like his character
itself is very like what he's there to
ask other soldiers to like like to fight
are you okay sir and then he can give
his speech he's people
he's like Saving Private Ryan if Private
Ryan died and it was just about the guys
that went to find him shows up to be
rescued
yeah drink and he mo caps the Nazis yes
hmm
yeah yeah yeah listed the Vietnam vet
for hire who always looks perfect forget
the fact that he's supposed to get home
dead in the nineteen seventy percent
come here look at that perfect hair he
never even gets dirty tryna and real
ordered a photographer who's essentially
playing Pokemon snap while all the
interested find the Pokemon snaps easily
that takes some of our best and most
talented working actors and gives them
nothing that even resembles an art
choices is really honest hi cuz I
remember one of my Chris's like she
doesn't take pictures of the monsters
why come on there's I mean she does take
pictures she does take pictures but
there's a few moments like come on
you're seeing something that's like
needs to be documented why are you not
doing it but I caught it ask Jordan and
he's like well no I think she's she's
marched in taking the pictures of the
tribesmen and stuff like that like that
circus oh hey I don't buy that which
helped me a little bit the point it
could be like she's terrified so she
doesn't think to take photos but she's
like a war for typically and there's
dragons shots of John Goodman taking
pictures ticky tacky and like the
character point of Furze that her
character has nothing to do yeah her and
Tom Hiddleston are just there to like
not hook up like they're just there
they're just they're there they're just
a billboard names that you go whose
income they're fun reactors they're okay
yeah yeah they're there but there's
nothing really for them to do yep
but Pokemon snap is a perfect analogy
because that game you're literally on
like a little raft going through a tour
of creatures and you you or anything she
didn't even take photos of the creatures
the other way yeah that's way better
than it had any right to be but it's not
without its serious flaws that's a
monster but but it is not I repeat not a
problem that it has too many really
helicopters wait what look everybody
thinks that there's some issue where
there's more helicopters in the sky than
there are in the boat and then calling
takes down an infinite amount of them
guess what you're wrong
there's a shot in the movie where the
camera goes around the boat and you see
in the back of the boat and guess what's
in the back of the [ __ ] boat
helicopters inside of the boat more
helicopters what's the boat being made
out of keen helicopters you know why cuz
you want to see Kong like the toy has
grabbing a keen helicopter you want a
pastry now is not the seat and use the
helicopter like a good baseball bat the
helicopter math makes sense yeah you're
honest trailer deep breaths dude do you
feel better now you know what I do can
you guys just do that funny name thing
that you do you got it thanks man
so the helicopter thing just tonight cuz
I've already seen comments look oh we
should lose the goals or like guys if
that was the joke
it just was him losing cuz he came in
with his clear he didn't have a little
bit of this like everyone keeps knocking
this helicopters like we actually had
thought out there's Commerce thing and I
just we just thought of swinging like
use that let's this is your nerds at the
moment to show you in on the joke like
the more you lose control and this dumb
stupid thing the funnier it is and when
to his credit he like he trusted us to
throw we did direct him like more add
stuff yeah like get nerd out on this
like no helicopter man makes sense and
he did it it was to his credit cuz I
have to me that moment was the moment of
revealing like guys he knows this is not
he was he was in on this he was he was
having fun about it to be fair he's
right because when I was rewatching the
movie I did not see the bay in the back
of the ship I only saw the front of it
and I did see that i was like
helicopters come from i didn't notice
jordan you were right about it i did
think that when i watched the movie and
i did miss that detail so I can see how
frustrating it would be if somebody then
criticizes you based on something that
maybe is a little detail the movie that
they missed yes right well just I think
he should know wants people to know he
did care he was thinking about these
things a lot and when you make a movie
this size there's a lot of cooks in the
kitchen
I'm the studio eyes and things that you
have to pick your battles of what you're
gonna fight for but to know that he was
actually paying attention those things
is fun but it is also just silly like
who cares of course you do you want to
see him knock down a cop in the sentence
the boat is made of helicopters is
always funny it's a joke literally is
making a joke clearly can't get over
this whole copter things guys it's
relaxed
I declare some time alright see our
starting funny names thing story Bennet
Tom Hiddleston derp that's hey come one
more time I dare you
John Goodall for your help Zillah Larson
yeah weird anime references there's a
lot more edge of all everything caught
with Skull Island 120 minutes or less
that was our over reference to it's
really not it's the movie is literally
everything wrong let's go out a hundred
twenty minutes or less it's the same as
every pop but however is have is a
trigger Jordan to everything that
happened there so it couldn't come up
with a better one we already use that
earlier on the trailer so we're like
alright let's just go Jordan so now his
honest title is gonna be everything Kong
with Scott yeah but if you read it
literally it's it's an island yeah it's
got everything Kong about it that you're
watching for about two hours to an
Anatomy reference he was saying that was
there was a lot more hidden a bunch in
there and video game references you know
after this I'm pretty you know
cautiously optimistic about the Metal
Gear Solid movie being the first good
video game movie because he'd made that
destiny - yeah I was just go and like he
really I don't know how much other
directors have been this way but like he
really gives a [ __ ] about video games
and about anime and about like getting
that across how many exclamation marks
were on the boat his hearts in right at
least he will try he clearly cares about
this stuff so hey I'm excited see what
is next sorry here's our but tag then
it's or less
to any of you who think we're just
capitalizing on all the drama we set
this up over a month ago the thing that
I'm not looking forward to is your
people drop in some honest trailer
outright it I would really weird on its
trailer we're trying to figure our tags
I was like I didn't want people to know
like we weren't just capitalizing on the
drama but then I was like well we are
still we get to capitalize on the drama
we probably would have done this and
then Jordan was before did we knew
Jordan was gonna help us back in July so
then we had it on deck and then I was
like alright well good timing I guess
maybe like 20% of our audience is like
this church knows who knows what's even
what are they talking about you're
learning also kinda have to be like
here's here's the thing so that you're
not completely in the dark but slash
film is gonna love it
[Laughter]
so yeah thanks can we cue them up and
we'll talk about our wrap is up man this
is a really weird on its trailer deep
breaths dude you feel better now you
know what I do can you guys just do that
funny name thing that you do I'm gonna
go start a Twitter fight with max landis
story low-key didn't need to be here
like James Blair about the giant monster
initiative out of his element Saving
Private Marlo
any RIBA bids cheddar Larson yeah we had
minor stuff that was it right yeah all
of them I want to do all of them yeah
guys Ola Larson just felt like okay when
we had them all cut together it just the
further it winter listen kept making me
laugh dolar no organs Ola Lars yeah I
was kind of hoping we could maybe flying
roars hey we'll have to save that about
this experience it was fun to work with
Jordan he was very honest and delightful
even though a lot of people think he's a
jerk he was very in on I knew was going
on and open and just wanted to make
clear like he wasn't against criticism
he clearly had issues with them but he
wanted to prove that he's like look I'm
totally about it so I think you know Sam
he showed up and was able to roast his
own movie in an exciting way Joe I think
in comment where our shooting eat a lot
and I think we'll get this feedback a
lot more is like oh well you work with
that guy because he likes you why would
you work with these directors and I'll
say this we want to so instead of
telling us that until the directors so
tell them that it's really up to them
yes it's a fair call if you really want
us to do something oh my god someone
work with you I would let Michael babe
punch me in the face
Oh
I would after watching me on the trailer
not very he's not as open as this guy is
I can't think of anything that I would
like to do more than sit here and debate
transformers age of extinction michael
bay for two hours dan vebe a hashtag
eBay hmm make it happen don't be mad at
us be mad at them I think he wants me
open in sight but I also like there were
comments the today else that were just
like oh you guys were so easy on it cuz
you worked with him like what do we what
were easy on ya remains ooh and he was
me I feel like you did really I mean
it's a it's a fine monster movie like
that that's why it's a tough one to do
because it's like okay people think that
we're here to [ __ ] on every yeah Charlie
that's not what we do and by the way
that's never what we've done like honest
trailers has never been a series that
shits on everything like we if it movies
in the mid mediocre will say it's
mediocre if it's good we'll say it's
good and I'm fine with it if it's bad
we'll certainly say it's bad but this
idea of like why are you so nice to it
you [ __ ] on everything like no we don't
and we and we never have like people I
think sometimes people mistake like well
take a good like we have fun with like
water soldier like we'll help you know
if there's a good movie that we think
has some kind of dumb stuff or whatever
well have fun with it but wasn't going
to say it's good if it's good we'll say
if it's bad if it's bad but this I feel
like we hate everything is we don't and
so and it's also though we've gotten to
the point now where we can't win it's
like oh why you know why why'd you shoot
on this or why are you so nice to this
it's like whichever way we take there's
gonna be people on the other side saying
like you were too nice slash kind to
this good slash bad movie so you know
it's almost a Kobayashi Maru yes I
literally would not have had enough to
even say positive or negative about it
until he showed up help us out yeah like
it was okay
had no name for this movie until he
volunteered Elvis rabies trailer it
would have been a very boring trailer of
us saying like those folks all right
it's got some problems but it's kind of
cool yeah just gushing about the plot
and the things that he does like it's
not typically stuff we get into so
intently on the manure trailers we
wouldn't gone a helicopter and no it's
like I think with him when you hear from
him then do
it actually is more effective than if we
had said that on our own and would have
felt just like we're just sour grapes
being jerks about the movie yeah this is
the hardest kind of movie for us to do
where it's like that was fun next yeah
that's the heart if it's a good movie we
can yeah like you said Spencer we can
like say it's good and then be silly
like Grandpa Joe's coke nails or
whatever with Willy Wonka yeah it's like
it was fine yeah we're not here to love
everything we're not here to hate
everything yeah we're here to just get
off her art man
anything else as we wrap this up really
know that rant that I just had was also
satire yeah myself okay about everything
no this is fun it's like like Andy said
like whenever people do interviews I
know you always said like what's your
dream and you said like my dream is
always for a director to come in and
write their own honest trailer so we did
it guys check it off the list who's
gonna be next directors out there
challenge is accepted let's take it in
well we will accept your notes and work
with you and we're not dicks what I'm
just gonna do about to tell us why we're
wrong your work again right here to like
make you not scorch the earth but
there's plenty of silly things about
these movies in this movie process that
you can come talk about so come play
with us
and then you at home if you're
complaining go tell Michael Bay to come
do it Michael Bay is now he was so in
that man actual fight actual fight
I'm telling I would be gout in like a
minute that was not energy alone cut to
you just in a Megan Fox outfit washing a
car we're not gonna do better than that
we'll see you next week for another not
another commentary always live here on
news after the trailer and or
Wednesday's little random time see you
soon bye bye thanks again to t-mobile
for sponsoring today's episode check out
what makes them America's best unlimited
network at t-mobile comm slash coverage
you